hello everyone I am sonalika Ray I'm the
bioinformatics project manager here at
Pine biotech and I'll be discussing
about metagenomics it's Evolution
sequencing types several ways to process
metagenomic data to pick the right
method I briefly discuss about the two
major analysis in order to make you
understand how easy the analysis could
be and finally showcase some interesting
visuals that are obtained by running
these pipelines that makes biological
interpretation easy and efficient so
first of all to talk about the
connection between disease and
microorganisms that has been established
in the 1800s these studies provided
important information about bacteria
function in isolation however it became
apparent that most microorganisms live
in complex communities many members of
which are impossible to culture in
isolation
today we know that the microorganisms or
the microbiota that make up the human
microbiome are not just unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but instead form highly regulated
structurally and functionally organized
communities attached to surfaces as
biofilms with inter-species
collaborations as well as antagonisms
that contribute to ecologic stability
however since the 1990s microbiome
studies were significantly Advanced
through such major initiatives as the
metagenomics of human intestinal tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project huge studies that have been made
possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing as a result skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota is
starting to be characterized each new
project represents vast opportunities
and challenges to determine which
microorganisms play key roles in the
development of certain environmental
conditions needed for healthy function
of human organs and which can be harmful
to it
due to the advances and metagenomic
sequencing and other omics Technologies
enormous database of sequence data from
such communities has led to the
emergence of computational metagenomics
which can help study the 99 percent of
uncultivable microorganisms in the
context of their natural environment
unlike other omics metagenomics does not
study a single organism but the whole
community at once a snapshot of a
collection of organisms directly in
their natural environment since the
genomes are so diverse this is typically
accomplished by sequencing a specific
marker portion of the genome instead of
all the genomic material present in a
given sum and why I'm telling you all
about this is because you'll have to
work with such data in the duration of
the hackathon
those sequencing principles vary between
different sequencing approaches to
mention the main difference alumina
specializes in short redraw sequence
data while Pac bio focuses on Long reads
or sequence data and the yield per flow
cell of Oxford nanotechnology is much
higher than pack bio because each
nanopore can sequence multiple molecules
now let's briefly discuss about the
types of metagenomic sequencing
techniques one is whole metagenom
sequencing or shotgun metagenome
sequencing that is relatively new and
Powerful sequencing approach that
provides insights into Community
biodiversity and function the other one
is 16s amplicon sequencing that is
recently developed technique and is
widely used to study microbiome directly
in its environment such metagenomic
sequencing focuses on 16s or 18s
ribosomal RNA that has to be Amplified
with PCR amplification
the 16 inch Gene sequences contain hyper
variable regions which are also known as
hvrs that provide species specific
signature sequences useful for bacterial
identification the benefit of
amplification is tied to the nature of
sequencing grid length which can
maximize effective output from
affordable sequencing Technologies
to account for the diversity of such
sequences they are usually combined into
operational taxonomic units or otus
which can be used to classify group of
closely related individuals
otos are formed from groups of closely
related genomic sequences and they
represent a cluster or a phylogenetic
plate that has a meaningful abundance in
a sample
such ODU sequences are annotated by
mapping on to a reference database such
as that of ribosomal database project
green genes or the silver database and
such databases contain taxonomic
information for the domains of bacteria
Archaea and the Eukarya based primarily
on phylogenes for small subunit rrnes
16s for prokaryotes and 18s for Eukarya
let's not talk a little bit about the
Practical analysis approach to analyze
metagenomic data on the team bioinfo
platform once analysis is processing the
data to pipeline that is based on
running a number of programs including
data to ape and phylosync algorithms
data do generates amplicon sequence
variance or the ASB tables which are
similar to otu tables but detailed in
that they tabulate the number of
identical amplicon sequence variants
from different samples microbial studies
utilizing data 2 provide high resolution
accurately reconstructed amplicon
sequences that improve the detection of
sample diversity and the biological
variance the data to pipeline implements
a complete pipeline to turn the paired
and fastq files from the sequencer into
merged denoised Chimera free infert
sample sequencing
by using the data to algorithm find
scale variations are identified and a
quality based model is produced we will
end up with most denoised Chimera free
inferred sample sequences data to
analysis will filter input data
de-replicate providing abundances of
unique sequence data and an ASV table a
denoised high resolution output file
the results obtained from the data to
pipeline includes a microbial awareness
taxonomy bar plot a relative and a
proportionate plot indicating the
richness and abundance of taxa
identified
pilocy clots based on the otu abundance
2D and 3D PCA plots to visualize the
cluster separation between the samples
of the data set Alpha diversity measure
that's a marisces the structure of an
ecological Community with respect to its
richness
now let's talk about the kind to
pipeline the kind 2 pipeline is an open
source bioinformatics pipeline for
performing microbiome analysis for from
raw DNA sequencing data the chyme is
designed to take users from raw
sequencing data generated on the
Illumina or other platforms through
publication quality graphics and
statistics this includes demultiplexing
and quality filtering
otu picking taxonomic assignment and
phylogenetic reconstruction and
diversity analysis along with
visualizations chyme has been applied to
study to studies based on billions of
sequences from tens of thousands of
samples
the advances in the analysis of amplicon
sequence data sets have introduced a
methodological shift in how research
teams investigate microbial biodiversity
away from sequence identity based
clustering producing operational
taxonomic units or the otus to denoising
methods producing applicant sequence
variants kind two plugins in the
pipeline on the team bioinfo server
exist for latest generation tools for
sequence quality control from different
sequencing platforms data 2 and D blur
taxonomy assignment and phylogenetic
insertion which quantitatively improves
the result the platform provides many
interactive visualization tools
facilitating exploratory analysis and
result reporting
along with the data 2 pipeline results
which included taxonomic bar plots PCA
and Alpha diversity measure kind to
pipeline also provides lists of results
that you could see here on the screen
which includes the alpha diversity box
plot which determines if an environment
has been sequenced to a sufficient depth
through evenness group significance and
Faith group significance plots
it includes kind to alpha Air fraction
which illustrates the number of samples
in each group kind to remove eukaryotic
generates an interactive bar plot of
taxa present in the samples it also
includes group significance plots which
include Alpha and beta group
significance and kind to core Matrix an
area of Alpha and beta diversity
measures that can be generated with a
single command of kind to the kind
diversity code Matrix phylogenetic
command reduces both phylogenetic and
non-phylogenetic measures as well as
Alpha and beta diversity measures and
then we have the core Matrix
phylogenetic command that generates a
plot as you can see here on the extreme
uh right side that includes the jakart
distance that includes the qualitative
measure of community dissimilarity break
your test distance which includes again
a quantitative measure of community
dissimilarity and weight unifract
distance and we Johnny flag distance
I hope you will now agree with me that
analysis isn't always complicated there
is a logic behind it and once you
understand the logic behind it then it
is easy for you to understand today what
I presented was a very brief overview of
the flow from the metagenomic study to
what are the various sequencing types
and then what are the different analysis
types and showcase you the resources
that you could use during your duration
of hackathon and utilize so now to
discuss how the resources could be used
effectively to build a solution or a
product of your own I would like to pass
it on to our CEO Mr India brosky